today I thought we could talk about
something just for fun that I was coding
at home right so a quite a while ago now
I did a video on maze solving and the
only reason I did that really was I just
thought that might be quite fun to do
right so I wrote some maze code and
quite a lot of people looked at the
GitHub and had a go at the code
themselves and so we're doing something
a bit like that today
now this actually came about because my
son came home my son my son is 10 came
home from a math class and what they
were doing was they were trying to find
all the different shapes you could make
with different cubes so kind of like
Tetris shapes how many of those are
there right and they just had to
basically try and Brute Force find them
all and then there's a question of like
well you know if you can now add one
more Cube how many new shapes are there
and you've got to add more one more cue
to all of those how many new shapes are
there and you know my son's teacher sort
of absent-mindedly said well I know your
dad does some coding maybe you can look
into this and one thing led to another I
lost hours of evening and
and you know it's a red flag to a ball
when you ask me like could you just do
this you know coding thing like well
obviously yes
um so anyway long story short uh that's
what we're talking about today or how do
I generate all the possible combinations
of Cubes just for fun right and is there
a formula here or is it there's no
there's no scene there doesn't seem to
be any kind of formula but you can
imagine that if you have sort of a
straight one and then you add a cube on
this side
or you add a cube down here that's the
same shape right because if you rotate
it it's the same it just makes an L so
there is a little bit of thought behind
this it's actually quite why it's quite
an interesting programming problem I
think is this in a 2d plane no so this
is in 3D right I'm going to draw 2D on
the page because I think if I try and
draw 3D we're all going to have a bad
time uh but but actually it's the same
exact problem it's just that there's now
an extra Dimension so my code is all 3D
but it's exactly the same problem in 2D
you can find a few people that had a go
at this before and in fact it turned out
on Wikipedia about the most ever
combinations of shapes are for 16 cubes
right no one's ever documented Computing
more than that now I have not managed to
get to 16 cubes yet but when I do you
can be sure I'll be editing the
Wikipedia page and saying I did it like
17 cubes what I thought was interesting
about this was I started programming it
thinking this is going to be quite
trivial right and it wasn't desperately
difficult
but actually there some thought has to
go into this especially if you want to
make it fast right so I thought we'd
just talked through what I did and I'm
not saying it's the right way to do it
and then maybe people want to have a
mess around see if they can improve my
code recode it in a different language
which is way faster and and so on and so
forth and let's see you know how far we
get what did you do it in uh C sharp I
did it in Python using numpy which is
essentially a lot a large array it lets
me do operations on arrays the reason I
did this was because it was the quickest
way to getting this running right
python is much much slower even with
numpy you you could speed this up a huge
amount by using you know C or Java or
something like this the first thing that
was on my mind was how do I represent
one of these shapes in memory so one
option was that I read online was you
could just have a list of coordinates so
you could say Okay a three long would be
not not one not not two not naught or
something like this right and you could
have a coordinate system that did this
but you then got to write a load of code
that transforms some coordinate systems
to you know rotations and things and I
thought well
that sounds difficult so what I'll do is
I'll just have a byte array that is
let's say three by three by three or two
by two or whatever and there's ones if
there's a cube in that position and it's
not if there's not a cube in that
position right that's very easy for me
to visualize in my head so that's what
I'm doing so suppose I wanted to do an L
shape a Tetris L you know then you might
have a two by
three array we're talking about n equals
four so you know and in 2D and you might
have a one here a one here a one here
and a one here and actually that's quite
easy to do in in numpy you can create a
two-dimensional array if you want to do
this in 3D you can create a
three-dimensional array which would
obviously have something going back here
which may or may not have ones and zeros
in other channels now
how do you then generate all of the
possible combinations of this well one
one option would be just to have a blank
array and just randomly populate this
with ones and see if you've ever seen
that shape before that's not a
desperately efficient way of doing it
because for example that is not a valid
shape right because these have to be
connected diagonal's not allowed so it
has to be you know that or that or some
you know some combination of ones that
can actually connect together one of the
ideas that I was reading about and I'll
put all the links to all the resources I
use as well in the in the description
but one of the ideas was why don't you
build all the next set of shapes off the
previous set of shapes right if you've
got all the possible threes you can just
put some blocks on it and then create
all the possible fours and then you can
create all the possible fives and so on
now it takes a little bit longer to do
this because you always have to generate
the previous set of shapes but actually
in practice generating the next set is
always so much slower that it doesn't
really make any difference so suppose
you were generating these this four here
and you wanted to know what are the next
set of shapes I could build from this
what I do is I pad this array out I
haven't really thought this through this
drawing but
sort of worked very nice numpy functions
to do just this right you'd have to do
it by hand this would be populated with
zeros and then I can say well okay where
are the possible places I could extend
this to right well one of them is here
here here here here here here here here
here
and here now sometimes depending on the
shape this will produce you a new shape
that you've never seen before so if I
put one in here you get a kind of Zed or
whatever that is if you put one here you
get a kind of upside down tee so you can
go through each of these and you can add
one in and say okay have I seen that
shape before it gets a little bit more
complicated because then you realize
well hang on a minute half of these
shapes are always the same as the ones
I've seen before so suppose you had this
shape here
which is let's say one one one
and you put one in here right now you've
got a kind of
t-shape whatever that shape is in Tetris
I don't know I'm sure there's a name
right but if you put one there
you've made the exact same shape just
rotated 180 degrees right now you could
include those are two different shapes
but actually you shouldn't really right
if you want to know all the possible
shapes you have to be able to weed out
all the repetitions what counts as a
rotation and what counts as a flip I
think you have to just try and visualize
in your head but obviously if you can
rotate around any axis and it aligns up
exactly it's the same shape that's the
idea
so when I was coding this up it was
quite easy to write something that
represented a queue a polyq is what
these are called as ones within a sea of
zeros and it was quite easy to write
some code that said okay these are the
next shapes and let's Loop through each
of those
it becomes a bit more difficult when you
want to say have I ever seen this shape
before given that I don't know what
rotation it was in last time I saw it
right that's when it becomes a real
headache and it's just it's just the
kind of thing where you think oh I can't
be too difficult and it's going to be
really really quick and efficient and
then you realize actually this it isn't
very easy to write really fast code that
does that because ultimately there are
24 possible rotations in 3D of this and
that's not not so good
so I I did I thought the first thing I
did was a super lazy version so what I
did was I just had a huge list of all
the shapes I'd seen when a new shape
came along I rotated it in all possible
directions and then looked through the
whole list right and those of you
watching and wincing a little bit at the
at the efficiency of that you'll be
absolutely right to do so right it was
shockingly slow I managed to produce I
think up to all the eights and nines
before my laptop said no I'm not not
going to go any further than that unless
you want to wait half a year
Savannah had another thought but think
about this and I thought well one of the
ways that you can improve
the speed of lookup is to use something
back like a hash table right or in
Python a set which allows you to find
very very quickly whether something is
already in there as I mentioned one way
in 2D if you've got a new possible shape
which is let's say this shape here and
you want to know if this shape has
already been seen before and you've got
a huge long list of all the other shapes
one of which might be that or that you
know and some other rotation then in 2D
what you would have to do is rotate this
four times and then for each of those
four look for all your shapes and that's
really really slow right in 3D it's 24
times it's even worse is it is there any
benefit in sort of storing each unique
one you've found in those 24 ways and
then when you're looking something up
you're just looking through 24 times the
data or is that just the same problem
reversed it yeah you end up at some
point you have to calculate all 24
rotations and then what you're doing is
you're trading off the lookups fee for
the memory you've used and so on I think
you know this is what I quite like about
this problem actually is that you think
oh this can't be that hard and then you
realize this is a bit of a memory mess
and this is taking quite a long time to
solve and apparently the world record
for this is number is n equals 16 and
I'm not even close to N equals 16. my my
laptop's maxing out n equals nine this
is an embarrassment right I need to do
something about this so what what I did
was I I decided okay so the first thing
to do is what is the fastest way we can
compare this
at each rotation to all others now one
nice thing is that in numpy when you
rotate an array you don't actually have
to rotate it in memory you just look it
up in a different way right so depending
if these are all pixels
you could imagine that if you looked in
this order or you looked in this order
or in this order that's equivalent to
rotating that shape and so actually you
can do this quite elegantly so in some
sense the rotations isn't actually such
a big deal it's the lookup if you're
looking through a list
then the problem you have is to find
this element you have to compare it to
every single element in the list that's
going to get very slow very quickly if
you've got one element in the list it's
one check if you've got 10 000 elements
in the list it's going to be 10 000
checks right you don't want to do this
essentially what we're going to do is
we're going to find somewhere converting
this shape into a simple hash numerical
code and we can just look up if the
code's in there and that can be done
much more quickly because often you
avoid any collisions you just jump
straight to the right place and you say
nope not not been seen before
now
hash functions don't work well with
objects that can change right mutable
objects where this can change and change
shape and be different shapes that's
hard to Hash so what I was trying to do
was find a way of representing this in
memory in a really concise way that also
didn't change
and so I could hash it really quickly so
I came up with my kind of Mike pound
special run length encoding scheme which
is never going to be used again and it's
terrible but I thought it would work
so what I do is I store a list of
integers that represent this so first of
all I flatten it and that means
basically take this and just lay it all
out in one row
and then I store the X the Y and the Z
size or X and Y if it's 2D XYZ if it's
3D and then for any string of zero so
this would be one two three four five
zeros before you get to the next one I'm
going to restore a minus five and then
for any string of
ones I'm going to store a positive
number so that would be one then it'll
be one two three minus three then
another uh that's two actually right
it's kind of worked I can't believe it
uh and then one two three four five
minus five now is this the perfect way
of storing these shapes probably not
right this is what I came up with while
I was sitting in front of a TV if anyone
can beat me then please do what were you
watching
there were no helpful programs on how to
do this that was disappointing
so now that I've got this I can fix this
in memory and then I can hash it and
that can be stored in offset and that
allows our lookup to be much faster
right so now
essentially we're not having to look
through 10 000 objects every time we
have to convert it into this one length
encoding format then we hash that which
is automatic in Python I I like when it
does things for me you know I have to do
it myself and then we can quickly look
it up in a set and say is it in there if
not we can store a new one and then and
that's really what my code does right so
if you download my code on GitHub you
can see what it does it essentially
takes as a command line parameter a
number of poly cubes to use right so n
equals 10 would mean you're generating
all the combinations of 10. so what it
first does is generate all the
combinations of one two three four five
six seven eight nine if it's already
seen them before and saved them to a
file it will just load that file nice
and quickly
and then
um and then it starts generating each 10
and actually I think I've generated up
to 11 or 12 now right and and it's
getting a bit slow and I got a bit bored
so I stopped right and I thought you
know I've got to give someone else some
work to do
um but there are lots of ways you can
improve it so first of all python is
quite slow right I mean python is fine
and and I've tried to use numpy
libraries to do this most of the time
partly because it's easier for me to
program and partly because that drops
down into C quite quickly and it's much
faster than if you're doing lots of
Loops in Python
but
multi-threading this doing it in a
language which is Fast By Design would
be better right and it might be more
memory efficient because I've made use
of some sort of slightly lazy numpy
libraries to find the bounds of objects
and rotate all the objects and stuff
there might be better ways of doing this
um
the key if you really wanted to produce
many many of these is that you would
need to find some way of encoding this
which accounts for rotation and I
haven't thought of one yet right and
everyone else I've asked has gone well
that must be easy and they've wandered
it off and come back with a bit of a
headache and not work to how to do it
part of my code crops them down to the
minimum bounds first because that's not
the true shape of the object that's also
slow and also annoying that I had to do
that but you know there are loads of
efficiency savings you could make I kind
of gave up and thought well this is good
enough what I'll do is I'll put it on
the internet and let someone else fix it
for me
um but it's a fun little project if you
want to have a go at it you can generate
loads of different cubes you can
actually render them on the screen and
then
um have a look at them right now up to
about n equals eight at which point you
know the graphing Library doesn't help
doesn't thank you for trying to generate
that many cubes
um but I thought it was a really fun
problem which was a little bit more
difficult than I thought it would be and
it's one of those nice problems where
it's difficult enough and it's a fun
challenge but you can actually do it
just just thinking about it could you
load this into something like beast and
get the gpus going yeah so I mean that
is sort of on my mind is that if I could
implement this in a multi-threaded way
using a different language python
doesn't handle threading very well
um but if I could do that I could run it
on one of these 100 core machines and to
see what happened right um and maybe
I'll have a go at that record
up and down and up and down and up and
down and up and down and get yourself
into a loop or here we've actually got
an actual Loop we might just go round
and round if we don't have any idea
about where we is so like 12 mod 7 is
five five times five is twenty five but
the next multitude